and Peter lolet as you mentioned Joe
he he says his eyes are wide open yeah
he's looking at different combinations
and maybe you never know what happens
in the game and changes he might look to
spar to te the devil's feel he added that
depth last season he's hoping to have
more of an impact as he came late last
[Applause] year Zack Jones is on number six that
shot stopped oh tough shot good job by shurin on
the close in stuffing Try by tley shot by Hughes
Luke Hughes was stopped there's Hughes again now
Jack Hughes that pass trying to get the through
Andre Miller clearing it attemp stopped by luk
Hughes Jack sends it across to jesser brat that
was for to Foley went by him here's luk Hughes
again now Jack cutting in the shot went through
hit his own man saved by yeah you know from the
back end as an 18-year-old that's a tough League
to play in and it is you know he got better and
better as the season went along what you won as
far as the development B passing off the Stick
of Wheeler Michael McLoud stopped nice play
by brenon Alman moves in drops it off wheeler
puts it in the crease it's picked wide by Bonino
sami's been noticeable again in this game here's
the defensive play makes steals the puck and now
he's got a little bit of time and he certainly
has offense to his game and B will coie is on
with dick Pino and tooo for the Rangers Jack
goes into the corner bino checking him NE finds
in the open man backhanded deflects in to Foley
putting the backhander in front and it goes in
for the first goal of the game ho actual bobbles
a beautiful pass no look pass through the seam by
name it's for Jack Hughes in the middle of it all
as usual controlling that puck drawing Defenders
to him gets it to nemit and he makes seen pass
that the Foley who stays with it one more look
there's the fake shot pass the Foley can't handle
it but he stays with it that's what veterans do
yeah as good as shurin has been he'd want that
one [Applause] back quick shot oh look at that
club save the pass up the middle right here Fox
tries to make a pass right on to the tape and then
nich follows up and that was Ty Thompson initially
initial shots blocked on the turnover great he's
been on that right side as we talked about it
looks he's little comfortable playing a right wing
not his his natural position but uh this is his
real opportunity for him to have a a good game
and and maybe out the G you are a real team for
Sure rinsky Shot went wide great sneer with a keep
in Long Shot deflect it a save rebound to save oh
Kier smid with two big saves Rangers just get that
puck toward the net it ends up being a bouncing
Puck it's fought off by Schmid but he stays raen
Schneider toley on him down the middle tooling
miss that shot stopped byid on Schneider might so
Joe yeah that's a possibility for sure great play
inde Rangers putting pressure on Nick Bono out
with a shot SW made the save DeAndre Miller he
knocked down Luke Hughes who's trying to check him
Miller works it ahead pass the front T shot by K
here's Miller with a shot that's deflected away
kono's got it and Granado has done a good job
there and the youngsters are coming on they've had
some outstanding crap pick driving to the n and a
save by Schmid on Alex bill wow another great save
Snider shot gets through Bal rather a good save
by Akira Schmid was it was eye opening for the
devil's organization Donny binski moves in after
Kevin Ball broke up a possible Breakaway that shot
is in Eric gusterson the defenseman Joe talked
about his offensive skills he fired that shot High
and beat shren and the Rangers have tied the game
there he is on the left side and then as Schneider
gets it here he'll look look and he knows he's got
his partner on the other side and by the by the
time shren can get over there there's a beautiful
pass and now guson has plenty of time and that
shot you don't have to get rammed into the boards
every boards Every Time Marino got that shot
through as he was being checked in a good save
by shurkin here's Luke Hughes moving with a puck
that's deflected Away by Guston play by noek in
deep foot gave it away the Rangers able to
clear it out Hughes back for it now Marino
works it ahead Nolan foot open man in front no
shake and a save made by shurin Rangers have
Zan Jad and belil it's aage had in coie will
kie getting penalty killing time with Guston
and Schneider tamy did a lot of that in Hartford
last year did Will [__] Jack Hughes good pass
down low save shurkin a Nolan foot again a wall
in net look at Jack Hughes nice little stop up
pass down low to tley the one time we saw it we
were slow out of the gates but I'm happy with
the way we responded he said guys are forming
chemistry we can already see that and he said
the second period was a step in the direction
we want to see in terms of speed systematic
play and our identity thanks John excellent
report and good to have Dan used as part of
the coaching staff third sorry Jo I was going
to say sam he's the same way in practice very
boisterous oh the chance they score J for Brad
on the period started four on four with nit and
love forier the penalty boxes and brat with
room chips one over Lou deing in the opening
minute of the third period Well the Devils get
up ice real quick and that's what jper brat does
he backs off Defenders and he chips the puck
wide and drives on to the net nice beautiful
little backhand saucer that's Kevin Ball there
with a beautiful pass in front drops it back
here comes off from he was stopped at the line
good play by Thompson gets a breakway pass and a
save by the right in instead elected to try and
make the play and Thompson made the play can he
oh he he gets a pass McLoud stays right because
our rivalry is built how are they rekindled by
both teams being good and we saw that last year
and I don't expect any different this year these
two teams will be going at it brecka away chance
Michael McLoud to the empty net and puts it away
well we haven't talked a lot about Michael McLoud
in this game but this is what he does I think he's
vastly becoming one of the better fourth line
centerman in the National Hockey League cuz he
brings a lot get a little perspective on both our
clubs certainly and and again this was a heck of a
game for a preseason one I think yeah love to say
the Rangers score a broken stick and the Rangers
wind up with a goal yeah Offman let a goal boy
he can shoot it and this was guson that went to
take the shot over to Offman there see it again
right over to off look how quickly he lets it go
yeah I think it went off Jack H the stick right to
Offman and hey coie digs for it Lazar is there for
the Devils Bono trying to pry it loose and that's
it it's over the Devils hold on for the 3-2 win